Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo episodio l'ultimo di Sons
of the forest Godetevi il finale perché
secondo me merita un sacco Buona visione
ragazzi ok Scusa Non c'è bisogno di
qualche minuto per riprendermi cioè
c'era il miliardario credo fosse con suo
figlio che stava combattendo questa
gebba de hat che è morto con una
fucilata pompa io ho schivato bambini
morti nel mentre eh Non saprei come le
descriverla meglio sta cosa Eh 10 su 10
questo gioco su Steam giusto Ah e tutto
questo il nemico number one non è ancora
stato sconfitto
'sto bastarda Ma io sono entrata da che
parte sono entrato di là adesso è chiusa
va bene
chi cazzo è quello No ragazzi Ma tutta
sta gente Dove è finita cioè il
miliardario tutti e due cazzo sono
finiti Ragazzi mi avete lasciato come
uno stronzo Ragazzi ma sono spariti
completamente dal nulla Poi tra l'altro
perché non non c'era C'era gente e non
c'è più vabbè va bene faccio un foglio
Fatemi leggere almeno capisco un po' di
trama sei film Cube futuri studi e
ipotesi potrebbero essere corrette che i
soggetti in questione sono al sicuro nel
cubo e di che cubo stiamo parlando
Ragazzi c'è un cubo l'artifatto causa
degli switch dimensionali Vedi che la
trama si infittisce ragazzi Aiutatemi a
capirlo eh anche voi nei commenti perché
sicuramente insieme faremo qualcosa di
decente Allora ok tiriamo Vai penso che
sia una questione c'è del paranormale
Comunque questo l'ho capito Salve qua ho
visto qualcuno prima eh non so dove sia
finito
Qua c'è sangue
penso sia qua dentro ragazzi altolà ah
ah ti ho visto la pistola silenziata
incredibile Perché non si capisce quanto
sia letale
[__] tua bambini morti
E vabbè quanto cazzo dura il bambino
morto Eh ho sparato Oh devi morire No
ragazzi è immortale
Oh e che cazzo bambino morto perfetto
ascensore di più Ecco perché
è la supposta ragazzi eh tranquilli
Madonna che casino Oh
Mazzara Golf un pattern Eh Meglio di
niente
Eh non funziona però
devi colpire Però allora ragazzi e fin
qua mi porto dietro una sedia che non fa
mai male ok Dove sono andati quelli
stronzi ma l'ho lasciato proprio da solo
ma più che altro da dove sono usciti da
dove sono spuntati da dove dove Oh
ma siete scemi
molto no Peccato la spalla Ahia ahia
[__] di tua madre
Pam eh raga la balestra è la mia Safe
zone Ok però non è morta è morta è morta
qua sento bordello
Che cazzo è No ragazzi ma quanti siete
oh oh
Madonna raga come L'ho saltato pazzesco
gran giocatore niente alla fine ho perso
tutti i dardi ce li ha lui [__] che
male Eh vabbè allora uccidimi che
a lui ce li ha tutti addosso Porca [__]
non muore Oh glielo spararti un milione
e devi morire oh che cacchio sei anni
per farlo fuori questo ma che è però ne
è valsa la pena mi dicono di qua c'è
qualcos'altro quanta gente che c'è qua
che bordello 'sto bunker devo usare il
pompa tra un po' eh Raga ve lo dico
Eccoli qua queste cartucce vi saranno
utilissime Beh oggi Questo sono io in
cucina questo comunque Perfetto allora
di qua Ok
di là non lo so vediamo
io vedo gente già che vedo gente la cosa
mi dà fastidio Va bene Vediamo di
utilizzare la tiglieria Eccoci qua buon
Salve
Eh vedi che con questo cambiano un
attimo le regole Ah ma io c'ho anche
l'arco non non sottovalutiamo l'arco
ragazzi che l'ho trovato da poco eh
quindi proviamo a utilizzare ancora Arca
vacca bambini morti ah no C'è un tizio
Ok a posto C'era un tizio
che cazzo fai
bello Uh cos'è armatura do armatura
d'oro Che cos'è ragazzi Scusatemi
armatura d'oro
Ma che cazzo è Oh
mi ha fullato Cos'è sta roba cos'è cos'è
non mi vedo c'è uno specchio No ragazzi
Voglio vedermi vorrei vedermi cioè
armatura d'Oro Mi mancava ragazzi e va
bene c'ho l'armatura d'oro l'armatura
Dominick È incredibile Secondo me
ragazzi eh non lo so
Oh buongiorno Salve almeno allegro è qua
Meno male che il Posti Allegri mi
mettono sempre il buonumore c'è una
porta
Io vorrei salvare la partita perché
questa roba è veramente lunga giorno
per non saper né leggere né scrivere
Buongiorno
[__] di tua madre Minchia
Porca [__] che schifo ma chi sei Ma
chi è Ma questo faceva schifo ragazzi è
terribile lo posso anche scuoiare Ma chi
era non mi ha fatto quasi Ah perché
l'armatura d'oro non la scalfisci in
realtà ti toglie ti tolgono di bene i
nemici però beh va bene a ragazzi switch
o solo all'arco perché secondo me c'è un
sacco di proiettili che potrei sfruttare
che non sto sfruttando Beh Vamos A meno
che non sia un'altra tessera No è buona
questa
caverne ragazzi o che si esce Quindi
teoricamente Uh siamo usciti raga Eh si
esce
Ma ragazzi ma che cazzo giorno
no notte più che giorno Salve Ula Che
cazzo è
bellissimo Oh
Eh minchia ragazzi veramente l'arco
faccio cagare faccio cagare
Pam Minchia questa volta l'ho beccato da
fare schifo a che l'ho preso in testa
aveva incredibile Kevin
brutto stronzo No ragazzi ah ah che male
Sto stronzo di merda No ragazzi l'arco è
terribile Non sono proprio in grado non
me la mira
Ecco se ce l'ho un metro Sì Kelvin è
tutto a posto dove sei Tiro io
a posto Sto stronzo maledetto Eh lo so
che ti fa male la testa eh Tranquillo è
tanto abituato Vabbè ragazzi eh Sono
contento Comunque se avessi detto quel
maledetto miliardario che sono usciti
ancora in giro con tre gambe non so come
l'avrebbe presa
bunker attento ragazzi Qua non c'è
neanche la neve non fa neanche freddo Ok
ragazzi uh la Madonna che è questo è
proprio più Ah c'è pure una porta qua
c'è chiuso da fuori questo bello ciò che
entra solo sopra se
Cioè se sei fuori Eccola con la tessera
di Virginia Patton sono entrato qua
vediamo
Kevin puoi venire qua eh puoi venire non
deve non devi fare Climbing se ce la
porta c'è la porta vieni Bravo Kelvin
Vieni vieni vieni vieni vieni vieni
vieni vieni vieni qua vieni qua Ah che
pigro di merda e un altro bunker simile
a quello di prima eh attenzione che va
sempre di sotto non so perché sono
ritrovato le medicine Eccole le Chiama
le trova proprio lui aveva ficcato una
botta de fori Meno male
benissimo Ragazzi allora vediamo se
trovo qualcosa Occhio che non ho più
troppi proiettili Eh devo poi gli switch
e per non utilizzare il fucile a pompa
che secondo me ci serve ok
Che cazzo è un coniglio Cosa minchia è
Five Nights at freddy's adesso Salve
vabbè Minchia è un coniglio molto
resistente a quanto pare Oh finalmente
una stanza che promette bene Eccoci qua
Ah Non ci si può andare più sotto siamo
arrivati più in basso possibile ok
No non mi faccio troppe domande raga
perché non si capisce una sega da che
parte di qua sento musica ragazzi che
sembra fa Mmm
vabbè è diventato BioShock Praticamente
sto gioco vai io shock adesso è BioShock
Chi di voi conosce BioShock Man of
goulture ragazzi
Ok questa è strano mi sembra un enigma
di residentivolo anche questo Ma che è
sta musica Oh bello ragazzi io ci vivrei
qua Cioè ma che figo scherzava Beh solo
il weekend solo il weekend bellissimo
soccorsi Collect Ah questo questo forse
era il libro di the forest 1 ragazzi che
quello aveva scritto il libro Il padre
di Timmy che è il protagonista questo
che sto comandando in the forest 1 aveva
scritto un libro alla fine potrebbe
essere quello che ho appena trovato è
pieno di proiettili ragazzi Stiamo per
finire nella merda io ve lo dico lo so
Stop la musica e qua mettono il
copyright lo so ragazzi che sta per
finire male come se non ci fosse una
boss Fight adesso tutti sti proiettili
che ho trovato vediamo
Beh per adesso si possa si può pure
salvare va bene tipo anche salvare
Quindi ancora peggio Cos'è questo email
collected
crossed burnings va bene Bello una
riparazione al bagno la farei Eh però
quando avete tempo ragazzi non è che si
passa là dietro
Sì
pazzesco cioè roba dietro il bagno
Aspetta che controllo prima qua no Va
bene
Vediamo cosa c'è dentro il lavandino
controllatina dietro il vostro bagno la
farei Ragazzi ma per sicurezza e si sa
mai che qua c'è un'altra strada Tra
l'altro
No non c'è una casa c'è una porta però
una porta ci vuole una chiave
una mano
la mia mano
per entrare Ci vuole una mano
perché con la mia mano si è aperta chi
sono io scusami per donne ora più
pallida idea però entriamo e
spiegatemelo nei commenti ragazzi Magari
volevo sapere Secondo me perché io già
ero stato in quest'isola quindi mi
riconoscono Cioè questo E questa era una
delle porte che c'era anche in the
forest 1 quindi secondo me non si tratta
più della facility tecnologica ma della
di quello che loro stanno cercando
sull'isola Questa è la porta
Salve C'è un tizio
Ah c'è uno di quelli prima che fanno
schifo che gli ho shottati col pompa
porca [__] Ma che schifo che fate
nonna di Dio E vabbè no ragazzi devo
tirare fuori Scusami sono bordello non
ho neanche non vedo un cazzo non ho le
pile merda No ragazzi è finita Non ho le
pile devo andare senza pile avanti non
vedrò una sega molto sega usa la
motosega che non l'hai mai usata almeno
sfruttiamo la batteria che figata Eh A
meno che non posso smontare la batteria
yo yo Porca [__] che male e non li
tolgo niente a sta merda
ok Un po' Gli ho tolto mi sa Eh vediamo
Credo che questa questa arma sia Ah
forse devo fare così
È un'arma totalmente inutile la motosega
però a quanto pare Vabbè meglio
scoprirlo Meglio tardi che mai
Mi scusi ho cambiato l'arma ok
Questa decisamente più utile a quanto
pare siamo a mortor siamo a mordor in
tutto questo va bene Non chiedetemi il
motivo però vabbè
cazzo non c'è non c'era Non ho mai
trovato la lava in the forest la lava ce
lo potevo spingere dentro quel tizio
Forse magari finirà Madonna è veramente
mordor buttiamo Se l'anello Ah c'è un
tizio
Vedo che la lava non gli fotte
assolutamente niente ma fottiamoci
neanche noi di lui andiamo avanti non è
che posso fa fuori tutti eh
Madonna ragazzi che siamo veramente
andando negli inferi terrificante
Salve
forse sai meglio che Pio la pistola
il taser ho preso Vabbè vediamo il taser
che quando fare un saltino Eh Yes mi
scusi
non capisco che vi siate impiccati non
posso così bello perché effettivamente
non era male almeno godervi la Spa
almeno quella Anche questa è termale ma
il taser è scarico lo vedo Come scarico
ma te serve a batterie tipo
no
c'aveva un colpo solo Vabbè ho anche
quattro granate Ricordiamocelo eh Allora
usiamo la pistola
almeno ho trovato i Proietti uh uh
Che palle che ho finito la torcia adesso
no c'è ancora gente entra lo vedo che si
muove C'è un tizio Ragazzi Adesso è Dark
Souls cioè Decidetevi che gioco volete
fare ma se li schifo sti Tizi
non rischi Però ragazzi non gliene frega
un cazzo della lava questi Porca vacca
li schifo No ragazzi troppi
Arrivederci dichiarano veramente tanti
di qua non ci passate siete grossi
effettivamente non ingaggiare sempre
potrebbe essere una soluzione Raga non
ingaggiate sempre i nemici Stiamo
andando sempre più a fare la Madonna di
Dio dove siamo Cos'è le miniere di Moria
cos'è cos'è Santo Gesù quanta gente così
Che c'è Che schifo qua devo fare Slalom
tra la santa la Madonna vuoi fare Slalom
tra la lava come scendo di qua come
scendo dove devo seguire i nemici cosa
che non vorrei fare Ma la devo fare per
forza Salve Fatevi i cazzi vostri e vi
faccio i cazzi miei ok
era per ribadire il concetto Non ho una
bella giornata oggi non so cosa ne pensa
lei tua madre è un po' [__] Vabbè Eh
mi ha tolto un'armatura Inquietante ma
fa niente ragazzi ne abbiamo ancora
Oh merda Oh merda Oh merda via veloce
corri
ah
quanti cazzo sono Hehehe No vabbè qua
non ingaggiare è stato un problema mi sa
mi seguiranno fino alla morte ma quanto
cazzo mi seguono e un'ora che mi seguono
aiuta
minchia sta parte terribile ragazzi è
terribile fatto Quanto vi segue quanto
mi segue quanto basta
e voi avete avuto pure il tempo di
impiccarmi con questa merda come
No ragazzi è terribile mi sta seguendo
da un'ora e mezza Ma vabbè mo mi gira
l'ammazzo Porca [__]
Minchia raga Ah ah ah quanti siete Santo
di Dio quanti Aiuto non so dove andare
Non ho più che non ho più la corsa non
ce l'ho no raga Sono troppi perché
veramente troppi devi correre c'è
l'inferno dietro la tua testa devi
correre Corri brutto pezzente merdoso
donna di Dio cioè guarda guarda
No ragazzi devo farlo Devo seccare Non
ho più proiettile Cioè veramente
incredibile ne avevo tre
Che merda ragazzi che merda non lo posso
neanche sviscerare ma con la switch mi
salta in bocca non posso fare niente
devo correre Corri corri testa di cazzo
però eh Che faccio
devo switchare arma non la posso
switchare che se Switch
veloce
Uh calmi eh
u la Madonna no raga quanta gente è
terribile ma che dove cazzo c'è
un'uscita da questo bunker era un bunker
era solo
un buca tiro un bunker sono entrato
l'inferno c'era un bunker di merda come
sono finito qua Eh
come come
era al liceo un mio amico mi ha detto
Apriamo un canale YouTube adesso sono
qua come come è possibile o Santa la
Madonna Però ragazzi Raga basta Elena
Vabbè sono troppi io non posso cioè
tanto mi hanno mancato sempre tranne una
volta forse non dovrei dirlo ad alta
voce sta cosa Eh
ma non non ha senso io gli spari sono
talmente tanti che se ne faccio fuori
Uno ce ne sono altri 62 quindi non non
ha senso farli fuori
Guarda che roba che male se mi toccano è
finita Se uno mi butta per terra sono
morto ma ragazzi arriveremo prima o poi
un punto che mi sembra terribile Puccia
qualcosa qua avete rotto il cazzo quanti
siete
che voi La cosa brutta è che si
accumulano capito si accumula
Guarda che roba
Madonna
ragazzi Vi prego basta Oddio
[Musica]
Santa
Io pensavo che fosse Kelvin diceva Ma
che cazzo fai qua Ma chi è
no no no no cazzo Chiudi proprio Ma che
sei sceso sceso Chiudi chiudi chiudi
chiudi chiudi chiudi chiudi
Sì sì
Cos'è un countdown
[Musica]
Ah questo è il cubo il cubo in
tredimensionale
adesso
[Musica]
That's Face per aggiungere stiamo
facendo tutti i giochi qua tutti quanti
i giochi Siamo arrivati a Dead Space
qualcuno me la spiega
Ah era questo che stava cercando i
miliardario quindi sta cercando un
accesso per un altro mondo che sta sotto
l'isola
Ah è scomparso
[Musica]
Porca [__] che figata meglio del VR
attenzione
E c'è gente dietro però fai come se
fosse a casa tua non ti preoccupare
[Musica]
Ah forse ho capito perché il varco
genera queste amebe strane che cazzo è
cioè l'elicottero c'è miliardario Salve
[Applauso]
a lui è il figlio non sto capendo una
sega raga lui è il figlio le miliardario
la e Virginia sta nel coso
Sì sì siamo qua ale c'è lo zaino dietro
Ah io devo decidere se tornare a casa
con voi
non ci credo No non ci credo ragazzi no
eh no no no no
vi prego vi prego no ti prego no
non ci credo
[Risate]
non ci credo No
non è vero dove sono No ragazzi
sono morto così alla fine del gioco
succedeva Vi prego voglio vedere cosa
succedeva alla fine del gioco Scusate ho
già capito cosa doveva succedere io
potevo decidere se rimanere sull'isola
con lo zaino oppure se scappare con Lory
in elicottero però non l'ho fatto ma
porca [__] perché mi ha tranciato la
pala non ci avevo detto Ah non avranno
mica messo il danno con la pala saranno
mica stati così invece l'hanno messo
[__] Merda Va beh Ragazzi vediamoci
il finale tanto era il finale non è che
sono morto al finale Io voglio uccidermi
ma come non sono morto mai non sono
morto mai sono morto adesso
era l'ultimo minuto di the forest voglio
morire voglio porre fine alla mia vita
almeno mettiamo in 4K ragazzi
incredibile solo io riesco a farsi
stronzate Comunque dai entra in sta
merda Non fare come me
Quindi alla fine il miliardario suo
figlio e io e Kelvin c'è Kevin
siamo fuggiti
Vabbè comunque
Comunque è una figata la trama Guarda
che hai vinto tutto il ridotto di merda
Il mio era anche peggio Il mio era
peggio
e alla fine c'è la trama era che loro
stavano cercando su cubo in
tredimensionale che ci stava nel
sotterraneo e quindi ragazzi anche
questo Gameplay si è quasi ho portato un
Gameplay al
99,9%, senza finirlo ho dovuto guardare
la cinematica finale l'ho dovuta a
guardare Ma porca [__] perché ho
saltata Vabbè bellissimo Secondo me cioè
il finale era figo Secondo me non è male
Più che altro mi fa strano che abbiano
vissuto tutti all'interno di questa
facility con le saune le Spa e che io
sia arrivato proprio nel momento preciso
in cui loro stanno scappando dice
qualcosa che non mi torna in sto casino
Però forse perché gli servirà qualcuno
che aprisse la porta con la mano cioè io
non lo so spiegatemela questa cosa nei
commenti ragazzi Fatemi sapere che cosa
ne pensate Però secondo me è veramente
figo quindi ragazzi Spero che questo
Gameplay vi sia piaciuto io sono rimasto
estasiato dal finale di the forest No in
realtà bello non il miglior finale che
Ma neanche il peggiore Quindi vai Fatemi
sapere nei commenti ne pensate
iscrivetevi al canale lasciate un bel mi
piace e noi come sempre ci vediamo ad un
prossimo video bella ragazzi